hi my name is Elizabeth hi I've been a
huge fan for years for years and I
actually got a tattoo of you and I was
wondering if you could sign it so I
could get that tattooed oh my God can I
see it is that I wanna
it's like a skull a skull it's a what
can you come you can come closer it's
okay not too close I want to go to
murder houses with us yes come on up
here come on up here it's okay okay I
like you got a tattoo of me and you're
petrified oh my God that's my skull yeah
that's my skull and is there a um and is
there a a cobweb coming out of my busted
eye we found our podcast art oh my God
look at this
that's incredible they did a really
beautiful job we have to yeah it's my
let me explain it's my skull
um and there's a cop my skull is smashed
my hair is still intact
because often hair stays attached to the
skull
something you'll well whatever I'll tell
you why I know that later
um and then these bottles of liquor yep
and so I drank myself to death
oh you like drinking
yeah it does look like you drank
yourself it looks like I drank myself to
death
no I don't want to change the story I
don't I'm still processing that I'm dead
and my face is smashed in okay you'd
like me to sign this are you sure I I
don't you're a very attractive person I
don't want you like right here can you
really think twice before you get this
put on your body this might devalue
things I know this will devalue her
foreign
okay there you go thank you
thank you sir all right
um okay uh don't
um it's gonna smudge I'm gonna go to
tattoo
it's cool you said are you been drinking
now
that's one just one yeah what'd you have
I haven't
okay all right that's cool though that
looks cool that's it's very cool and I
love that the person who does your work
is is really talented thank you okay
okay well I don't know what to say I'm I
feel like I'm responsible for you now no
should I come live nearby okay where do
you live oh stop it
I was born and raised in Whittier yeah
it wasn't Nixon in Whittier yeah he went
to um with your college yeah yeah
okay thank you sorry all right I don't
know how to end this conversation
I'm being very honest I'm very uh
stunned yeah
yeah can I get a picture of you
afterwards uh yeah yeah of course yeah
yeah stick around
um I will take a picture with you and I
mean you're getting you have my well
it's not my face it's my skull and and
now my name tattooed on your arms so of
course I'll take a picture with you it
was really nice to to meet you yeah I'm
honored thank you